after an 1800 kilometer flight I'm back
in Kuala lumper for the final day of my
Malaysian Great Escape
the executive chef I met at the
beginning of my trip has entered me into
a national cooking competition this will
be a very public test
today's the first time when I'll have a
chance to sort of bring all that
experience across the week together onto
one plate I've got to grips with the
fragmented style there holds strong
Chinese influence strong Indian
influence and of course at the core a
traditional Malaysian style so way tough
because there's textures heat sour
sweetness
forget it all right all three balances
the competition's taking place in one of
Cal's most prestigious hotels and that's
also home to one of the country's
leading catering skills today's when
your recipe will be taught to the next
generation of professional chefs back in
1992 for national chef of the year yeah
I definitely want to come last but I
wouldn't mind winning I spent the last
week playing sous chef to some of
Malaysia's toughest auntie's but today
I'm cooking my own Malaysian recipes
head-to-head against five of the
country's best female cooks how are you
yeah they're each famous for a different
style of Malaysian fusion cuisine it
smells amazing Wow watching very closely
oh yeah thank you
so today you have to prepare the coconut
rice at the same time you can prepare
three side dishes today we have forages
for your event and then I'm will be take
care for the kitchen operations cool
thank you the best auntie wait
thank you we need to prepare traditional
Malaysian coconut rice and three side
dishes of our choice I'm starting with a
Chinese chicken dish inspired by the
Executive Chefs month that I met at the
beginning of the week
so no marinated chicken first is the
Chinese influence chicken capita soy
sauce
[Music]
Chiqui competent on this way just see it
off
the chicken and let it sit in that soy
sauce flavors it inside which is nice
it's cooked on the bone so should be a
lot of tuna
I've noticed that the auntie's are
paying special attention to one dish in
particular you starting to cook your
rice now why so early you're not telling
me
okay what I'm amazed that everyone's
starting to steam their rice there's
over two now has to go and put the rice
on already only takes 20 minutes to cook
the rice is going on that early for
reasons so can't beat them join them and
about three minutes time I'll be putting
my rice on but first I need to get my
second dish started of my take on the
traditional Malaysian slow-cooked beef
rendang I was taught by our Nene
throwing down I've just cubed it so I've
got a bit texture and they won't bite
through it anti Lee's restaurant she
sliced it a little bit too thin so they
lost that texture
bite finally be nice this break and
coconut rice should be the easy bit
coconut milk in some lemongrass slice
the tops and smash the bottoms I've
never used a rice cooker before but all
the auntie's are using them I'm
following their lead and on just a
button
I hope the [ __ ] best okay Fandango
Juicin chickens fine Weiss is on he is
busy yeah but I don't see anything like
you know the Malaysian Asian is he doing
something like Western why bang bang
let's come down there that's much better
exactly the way I want you to there's so
many things on the go I was like
breastfeeding five babies at the same
time chicken beef rice but the one thing
that should be a doddle could prove to
be my undoing that's [ __ ] that [ __ ]
did you wash your eyes you didn't wash
it and how do you sing before it's just
uh automating you just living on your
cook wait sir why is done overcooked you
put the coconut milk in yours as well
yes yes
but I think I might have spotted the
anti secret she got herself a Ferrari of
rice cookers my rice themo cook too
quickly and you have another one in case
that's faulty but one like that with a
digital phone on it I'm not blaming the
tools but it just you know it cooked too
fast it's mushy at the bottom and raw at
the top
thank you very much now you be the posh
one in rice kneel down not taking any
chances now this time I'm going belt
embraces doing a backup batch in my
flashy new rice cooker
[Music]
with minutes to go I'm racing to get
finished my final dish is an indie
inspired from Currie like the veggie
meal I cooked for the prime minister
shrimps fried really quickly and then
finished inside the light coconut curry
now I've got to hope these dishes work
together nice
five more minutes I'll go I'll go
I got two minutes to serve this thing
I'm [ __ ] I'm serving my rice wrapped
in a banana leaf alongside traditional
Malaysian garnishes
Malaysia's love their food spicy so I'm
just hoping that this might be enough
and to go with the rice my three side
dishes every plate individual numbered
so the judges can't tell who's cooked
what
you drop this tray I'll hang you upside
down by your balls from the Petronas
Towers I figure don't sneeze the foods
going out to a restaurant packed with
Kuala Lumpur's leading restauranteurs
and food critics but the people who
really matter tonight other judges 5
Malaysian chefs from some of the
country's leading restaurants they'll be
judging each of my recipes on texture
and taste and they'll expect all of the
dishes to come together to create a
balance of flavors and a harmonious meal
[Music]
very mild even not subtle but then
together we complement each other time
to find out if I've managed to beat the
Malaysian artis at their own game
we now have the third prize it's number
five Norma's won
and the second prize goes to thank you
very much Wow I'll risk upon my family
its bit laughs with the Hat for your
family nice well done
number one answer humble question I want
to come back next year to take your
crown auntie yes okay a week ago I had
only ever tried a couple of Malaysian
dishes but I'm leaving with a new
understanding of one of the world's most
unusual fusion cuisines and it's quite
awkward to begin with because I struggle
to get my head around it
because I couldn't understand that
strong Chinese influence and then the
Indian influence and then what is
Malaysian cooking them and it was a
combination of all three so that's what
I've been struggling with and it took me
to the end of the week to come to terms
with that because when you taste it the
first time Wow the penny drops you think
Jesus that is extraordinary stay close
to your auntie because that's better
civilized
[ __ ] amazing